so the college enrollment rate at the
recent U.S school high school graduate
has declined to 62 percent in 2022 from
66.2 percent in 2019 that's just three
years ago as more young people opt for
Blue Collar jobs in a strong labor
market job growth in Industries like
Leisure and Hospitality construction
manufacturing and warehousing which
don't require college degrees has
outpaced overall job gains the low
unemployment rate for teenage workers
reaching a 70-year low of 9.2 percent
last month has led to significant pay
increases hourly earnings for leisure
and Hospitality workers Rose by nearly
30 percent from April 2019 to April 2023
wages are also higher in Industries with
additional training requirements like
apprenticeship factors contributing to
the declining College enrollments
include the high cost of Education
College closures and uncertain return on
investment that's a big one right there
Tom uncertain return on investment and
this is Wall Street Journal saying this
that may maybe the biggest one out of
all of them in a lack of confidence and
the value of a decree many Americans
question the worth of a college degree
further discouraged by improving job
prospects in Blue Collar Fields Tom
wow this is a lot
um but this is basically this is one of
those stories where you read it you step
back from it and you go well actually
that makes sense and sort of you saw it
coming but you weren't paying attention
so what's happening right now is um
there's something that was left out on
that summary there you didn't leave it
out padded it wasn't in the
um wasn't in the in the story and that
is that there is a
fair to say is about 35 percent people
in this country are conservative and
very concerned about the woke things and
you have a lot of parents that are out
there that are going to orientations at
colleges saying what the hell am I doing
here sending my kid to be indoctrinated
in a woke institution so there is also
parents stepping back and saying wow is
is the college Roi worth it I'm about to
put you know 25 to 40 Grand a year in
there put 100 160 just to put my kid
through a basic school and
that's being met with hey wait a minute
you know um my uncle was a plumber and
you find out you can make a hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars a year I
looked up as a journeyman plumber not
after 20 years after like five years so
the trades are heating up the blue
collar trades are heating up giving you
know
um real Alternatives and the job market
on small business on the other side now
small businesses we're not talking about
the plumbers we're talking about small
businesses that are um 10 million
dollars in sales that's small compared
to you know large corporate and what
they're seeing is a lot of people coming
in and they still want the covid package
you know well you know there's you're
looking for a lot of bookkeepers there's
a quote from a bookkeeper that said
somebody came in they're looking for 61
bucks an hour to be a bookkeeper and
it's like 10 million dollar company you
would think wow can you afford that no
you can't
um from a perspective of what you're
talking about here I think it's
important if you're comfortable talking
about this
you made a very big point about the fact
that parents are worried about sending
their kids to a woke School the other
day uh my sister and I were talking to
my niece who is wanting to be a lawyer
and she's going to a school and we're
having these conversations about you
know the school you're going to you're
going to spend a week there there's
going to be woke experiences there that
you have to just kind of be prepared for
you just took your daughter one of them
your oldest to go to different
universities if you're comfortable
giving names do it I won't do it what
was the experience like and how
immediately did you see signs of these
guys doing the woke thing in University
some of the biggest universities in
America because your daughter has a 4.6
GPA so she's only going to the best of
universities yeah well so we did the
standard thing uh we went on tours and
you register online and you can go to on
a certain day and they take you on a
tour the first part of the tour is as
you go into a large room and there'll be
somebody from admissions talking and
then there's usually like a senior who's
there to talk about the school the
experience of school and to personally
say hey I majored in this this is what
it's all about but they also stay with a
script that comes from the school itself
and the first Topic at a at a top 15
school that is located in the heart of
what you might call Music City and I
think we know who we're talking about
here the colors are black and gold
um they um they basically said Anne
welcome
you are here for a tour we're so proud
of what we've done here there's a lot of
things going on here and one of the
first things we want to let you know is
how in we're not just inclusive we're
inclusive and also providing Services
you can get gender reassignment surgery
and support here at not our health
center but the hospital that's part of
the research to answer this question let
me ask you how many minutes before the
orientation started that message was
given that was within the first five
minutes so tell me you're joking Tom no
I'm not I'm no I'm not and I had a
parent in front of me turns her turns
around and looks at me and and she makes
eye content and under her breath you
could hear her say she didn't curse she
was like starting with this you know and
then when we so about 20 minutes this
was a script this person was going off a
script and then said my name is so and
so yeah and this is yeah yeah exactly
but he he identified as pronouns too he
said I go by you know I go by you know
the AI that was a Shakespearean pronouns
because they're in college
so I saw a lot of people that were there
and then and then we we went on a tour
and there was a father that was there
who said something very very telling he
says I understand everybody's going to
be here just tell me about the
university and why this is the place for
my kids going to get a fantastic
education so he was not like going off
right wing and going off on somebody but
you so you have that going on as well as
the inflation intuition and college
closures and the on-campus off-campus
controversy we had during covid wait I
get the same diploma and I'm not on
campus and I don't have the labs but I
have to pay the same tuition remember
that story in milikovid that parents
were asking why am I still paying lab
fees and all these other fees to school
if it's basically the remote education
now because you're saying kids are off
campus so now I'm getting like a remote
degree like Grand Canyon University I
can you know go online and get one of
those online and so what's is happening
is the high school grads are seeing all
this put all this in a pot of chili and
then say you know your your uncle was a
plumber you can make 175 a year a
plumber after five years do an
apprenticeship get your license get a
couple trucks and you can have a great
air conditioning pump the trades so
there's a lot of trade jobs are out
there and small businesses under 10
million you know they aren't going to
get you the work from home thing and so
these things are fighting with each
other and you step back from it and you
say I am so surprised
Adam yeah for me this this entire story
comes down to one word and that word is
disruption
um we're we're we've seen this in cable
news to me college is the young version
of cable news we we went over the the
stats the other day where uh how many
five years ago ten years ago 70 of homes
had cable yeah and now it is now 40
um things have been disrupted whether
it's money in Bitcoin whether it's
politics and Trump and Outsiders going
against the system whether it's College
whether it's education there's no need
to go the mainstream traditional route
and if you actually look at the numbers
in college in the 1970s 1980s 60 of
college attendees were men 40 women now
it is completely flipped women make up
60 of college attendees and men make up
40 so we talk about this concept of
hypergamy and women won't date down
that's also becoming an increasingly big
problem where women are making more
money money they're more educated where
they won't necessarily date down a
blue-collar guy Tom made a great Point
sometimes you can be a blue collar guy a
plumber make 150 Grand a year hell yeah
buddy make that money the problem is
would a woman date a plumber and that's
something that men need to consider when
they go into college now for me college
comes down depends on the kind of a
plumber dummy let's just yeah that's
true
conferences uh but go ahead keep going
you have different options these days
that you do that's your sponsor read
right there that's exactly right you do
have different options these days check
out my people as a man specifically
um you can be you can get into
entrepreneurship you can get to
technical school you can get to
apprenticeship
um there's so many different options
that didn't exist
20 years ago when this whole you know
should I go to college not go to college
debate really started rearing its ugly
head and why did it rear its ugly head
let's get real here college has
increased what a thousand percent ROI in
the last 20 years has education
increased a thousand percent has
increased ten percent twenty percent as
College even taught you more the we all
know that I mean this also comes down to
indoctrination versus education we've
highlighted many times that what one in
11 professors are on the left when it
comes to call is that the number these
days
thirteen to one one out of 11 not on the
left no on the left no before every one
conservative Professor some say 11 some
say 13 but for every conservative
Professor 11 to 13 are on the left yeah
you're saying the same thing I think
yeah I think at the end of the day and I
went to college I I'm glad I went to
college I did the whole college
experience that's great I'll tell you
what if I just entered the real world
18th probably would have made a handful
of mistakes it's sort of easy to have
that four-year window of
effing up and making F in mistakes which
is fine but at the end of the day this
is a major decision but besides getting
married and having kids what's the next
biggest decision that a young person has
to make going to college I mean if
you're going to spend a quarter million
dollars of student loan debt uh you need
to really think about that at the end of
the day this comes down to the bottom
line what's the bottom line
um what's the ROI on you going to
college now I don't want to be
on College if you can get into an Ivy
League school if you can get into a
grade school if you get to a state
school if you get your college paid for
if you get free tuition if you get a
scholarship go for it but if you're just
going to some small liberal arts school
outside of state that you're paying out
of state tuition you're paying 50 Grand
a year to get some basket weaving
education it's like what's the ROI on
that house and that's something that you
really need to consider so so so so so
far I'm gonna go to the next story so
far there's a few things that we got one
disruption which he's talking about two
is the value the same as it was before
three the woke which is scaring parents
out and four I'm gonna just start making
money right now why do I need to go to
college I can make money online creating
content doing this there's so many
different ways to make money this is all
bad signs for colleges and they're not
helping themselves as they get woker and
Walker and Walker and Pat my question
too is about what why are they all like
bowing down and like letting these the
whole woke ideology the whole Trend how
is this small minority taking over and
because think about it pat they're not
stopping companies like we've been
talking about uh Dylan Mulvane they try
to Bud Light guess what failed I am
finally convinced what's happening now
it's not the colleges man it's everybody
knowledge no no it's not the colleges
the the you know you know how we always
go back to you know who's the they yes
who's the they who's the they you know
we got the man in a house your seat's
right here uh uh so who's the vague
who's the they you know who's the day
who the who the people are here that are
the power you want anything you're good
okay so that that's that they that's
that isn't the college no the they is
colleges need these big endowments to
get the monies so for them that are
getting the big endowments the college
money themselves they have to kind of uh
abide by what they want them to do and
if you don't you're replaceable who got
you the job so think about it who placed
you in this University to that job that
same person that placed you in that
University Dean whatever the job is they
can take you out your loyalty isn't to
the students your loyalty isn't to the
kids loyalty has changed loyalty has
changed from CEOs of s p 500 companies
and University Deans to students and
parents to now funders and where the
money is coming from and if you don't
you don't provide loyalty to those guys
you lose your position your job your
money all of that stuff so and there's
one small not so small thing the whole
concept of student loans they've been
able to raise tuitions at astronomical
rates and not worry about the consumer
path the consumer is the student
right the consumer is the student and
the second consumer is the parents that
are paying the bill for the constitute
for the student so student loans have
been there so that they can raise
tuition and the college says just get
the student loan and who's backing those
loans the United States government I
still think though going to us going to
a school like and I know what school
that you were talking about within the
first five minutes for them to say Hey
listen we do gender reaffirming surgery
if you have a crotch we'll chop it up
what the what are we talking about by
the way what about the school the other
day we went and we watched this new
movie by Sebastian Maniscalco and Robert
De Niro okay how was it it's freaking
funny yourself it's actually a very good
movie within the first five minutes a
gay couple's getting married okay within
the first five minutes
Tico looks at me and I took my dad he's
81 years old yeah okay and he wants to
watch the Nero movie Tico doesn't like
this kind of stuff he wants to leave so
we stay for dad two other times they had
the you know examples of what happens in
there to touch the you know ESG score to
be right so these guys are going out
there raising 50 million dollars for a
movie like this and the guys are saying
we'll give you 50 million as long as
your cast is this this this this that no
as long as your script has this we'll
approve it it's no longer who you think
they're loyal to it's changed anyways
let's move on to a different topic can I
ask one thing since you're 20 seconds
there you go there's since you're a
stats Guy this is something you should
consider somebody consider valuetainment
because we believe so heavily in stats
you've seen the stats where a high
school graduate over their lifetime will
make a million dollars yeah a college
graduate over their lifetime will make
two million dollars a master's degree ba
in everything with that will make three
million dollars so that's highlighting
the upside of college they'll kind of be
like yeah don't worry about the debt
stuff don't worry about all the nonsense
don't worry about the gender reaffirming
surgery don't worry about that just
follow the money but if there were stats
out there which I'm sure we can put
together on all right if you go this
route not like an on-called drought the
entrepreneur route this is how much
money you can make the Elon Musk route
if you will the Jeff Bezos route the
Mark Zuckerberg route dropping out of
college that's something that I think
should be highlighted more and not
pushed to the side so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you
foreign